Ibrahim Assange is an agricultural
expert and a visionary he spends a great
deal of his time in Mackay a town in
Senegal he's working to win people over
to sustainable farming much of that work
involves peanuts they were traditional
crop here in Senegal luck until de la
Rashid Dawson Boone peanut farming was
introduced by France when Senegal was
still a colony peanuts were almost the
only crop in the entire region the
impact of that was enormous less impact
so you see an arm that was more than a
hundred years ago even today around half
of all farmland in Senegal is used to
grow peanuts if they grow at all that is
a century of monoculture has damaged the
soil the effects of soil erosion loss of
nutrients and desertification are
visible everywhere way local farmers say
the soil is almost entirely depleted
plants can hardly take root anymore
monica CA o Navi peanut monoculture led
to extreme soil degradation a loss of
biodiversity means a loss of Natural
Resources the soil the water trees plant
biomass it's all gone to the party the
peanut harvest has suffered as a result
that's a major problem for people here
in Mackay and all of Senegal peanuts are
one of the country's main sources of
export income but harvests have dwindled
this warehouse is where local farmers
store their harvest
their farms extend over vast areas but
their harvests are meager by comparison
many farmers earn only around 200 euros
a year that's why many locals have been
turning to other crops like cassava but
even that can't assure their livelihood
over the long term collision a la r EV
that's the reason why young people don't
want to stay here well when they're old
enough ready to earn a living they leave
the villages first they go to the city
lemme Gresham and then often they
continue onward to Europe or the u.s.
apres unnavu the little una belleza
thousand e mmm quite often what happens
is terrible the young people are so
desperate so lacking in hope that they
get in boats small boats simple ones and
try to cross the Atlantic in them you
know Ali traversal Atlantic many of the
farmers who remained in Mackay have
joined together to form a cooperative
which runs a small oil production
business the peanuts are shelled and
peeled and then put through the press
several times the co-op members use the
oil themselves and sell the extra at
local markets
the days of ample harvests are long gone
but even a small increase in yields
would make a difference Ibrahim asek
believes the only way to make that
happen is to switch to sustainable
farming without chemical fertilizers and
pesticides novel calabar Evelyn we have
to work with nature instead of trying to
dominate it we need ethically
sustainable farming methods that means
ecological and organic farming methods
that's the future of farming not just in
Senegal but around the world in 194 many
in Senegal organic farming is still an
unfamiliar concept but Ibrahim a sec is
committed to making it a reality